Speaker 1: Radical and repugnant. Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE now has
made the very brave declaration that
she refused to wear the COVID vaccine.
I don't know what on earth that means either. She
filmed this video alongside her new partner, Brian
Glenn. That's the dude who always looks sunburned
and stoned during the Trump rallies on Right Side
Broadcasting Network and interviews people. They
are now together. Much speculation about whether
Glenn is responsible for the breakup of Marjorie
Taylor Greene's marriage. Don't know. Don't really
care. But they both now are talking about masks
and vaccines. Marjorie Taylor GREENE says she
never wore the vaccine and her boyfriend actually
seems to dodge the vaccine. Question when she
says, you know, you're not vaccinated. He seems
to skip over that and only talk about masks, which
is kind of interesting. Take a look at this one.
Speaker 3: I'll be upfront and honest with you.
I'm not vaccinated. I always refuse to wear the
vaccine. And I wore mask a little bit some of
the time. But it got to a certain point
where I refused the mask as well. Brian,
you're not vaccinated. You're not you. I didn't
want to wear the mask at all. And a lot of
times the airport I was asked to put it on and I
would for a second and I would take it off. Yes.
Speaker 1: There you go. Very, very proud and
powerful act of defiance. So anyway, he just
skips over whether or not he's vaccinated. But she
says she won't wear the vaccine tinfoil hat she'll
gladly wear. But the vaccine she's not willing to
strap on to herself. So what I think is the most
important, you know, we as we continue to just
learn and get more information about everything
that went on in the COVID era, There's learning
for everybody to do. You know, the original
vaccine very effective at preventing transmission.
The more recent versions of the vaccine against
the more recent variants almost completely
ineffective at preventing transmission, still very
good at preventing illness or death, and reducing
the odds that you end up in the hospital. Okay. So
we're learning about that. One of the things that
we're also learning about is the hypocrisy that
knows no bounds from members of the Republican
Party and people like Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
They cry about masks and how mask requirements
are discriminatory and they're potentially
illegal. They love to say, etc., etc.. But they
are completely on board with this systematic
push for laws that discriminate against LGBT
people and folks who aren't Christian and women
telling them you don't have any right to decide
for yourself with medical professionals what is
right for you and your family. We're going to tell
you no abortion. It's going to be against the law
and we might even prosecute you or the doctor or
whoever if you try to procure an abortion. That
this idea of discrimination, you're discriminating
against me by saying I have to wear a mask. To the
extent that there were vaccine requirements at
certain points in time, the businesses are the
ones now discriminating. Wait a second. You have
been pushing a politics for decades of letting
businesses do whatever they want. You don't even
want many of these folks don't even want protected
classes of people. They always say, listen, a
business should be allowed to say we don't serve
black people or gay people. And then customers
can choose not to patronize that business if
they don't like that policy. For decades, they've
been saying don't restrict what businesses can
do. All of a sudden, businesses say, well, some
of us are going to require a vaccine or some of
us are going to require, oh, that's a that should
be illegal. You're discriminating against people
who don't want to wear a mask or shouldn't wear
a mask because of carbon dioxide conspiracies or
whatever the case may be. The hypocrisy knows no
bounds even on serious issues that they claim to
be at the top of the policy questions that they
believe our government should be dealing with. So
they are hypocrites. Many of them are also liars.
You know that. I go back to the Tucker Carlson
ranting against the vaccines for so long. He and
his family almost certainly vaccinated. Fox News,
had that policy in place where if you weren't
vaccinated, they really made your your your day
to day pretty tough. And he never mentioned he
was being subjected to it. So they often lie.
They are hypocrites. But the real victims are the
people who don't really know any better. And they
follow them and they believe the things they say
and they make decisions that are disastrous for
their own families. And I'm not talking about
necessarily bad medical decisions. I'm talking
about economic decisions, employment, all sorts of
decisions. The people spouting the nonsense don't
suffer. But those who have Fox News and Marjorie
Taylor Greene's podcast and Real America's Voice
as their primary news sources, those are
the folks that suffer at the end of the day.